So
Ich mein es kann halt nicht am Encoder liegen von der Grafikkarte, der hat überhaupt keine Probleme
Aber es wird sich finde letzten drei monate oder zweieinhalb monate
Immer top funktioniert alles jetzt call of duty stream übelst im arsch
Jetzt habe ich keine Mistframes mehr WB soll ich stellen mal kurz die
Wb soll ich stellen mal kurz um die lautstärke von dir noch mal
Wunder, dass du die ganze zeit einsteigen musst
Ja du bist leiser als gestern
Vorne hast du noch gemeint ja super
Ja da war aber auch kein Game Sound
So jetzt passt
Ich invite dich
Wollen wir mal einen anderen modus ausprobieren
Irgendwas, was gibt es sonst so
Ich guck mal was könnte man sonst noch spielen
Ob jemand domination spielt
Komm ich spiele mal eine runde domination
Mal gucken wie das hier umgesetzt ist
Jo probieren wir mal aus
Bist du drin in der party
Jo
So leute wir gucken jetzt mal wie das läuft
Ähm, sonst ist irgendwie meine laune gerade sehr schlecht
Jaja war habe ich gespielt
Du hast ja auch diese preorder ausrüstung mit den gelben handschuhen oder leuchten wie so ein weihnachtsbaum
Echt ich habe nicht preordert
Vielleicht habe ich einfach schnell genug bei release gekauft
Das zählt dann auch
Wann hast du den gekauft
Ähm
Ich habe überlegen wann kam es raus am dritten
Dann habe ich glaube ich am dritten gekauft
Ich meine das war das preorder zeug da
Komisch
Das kann doch das kann sein dass es noch als preorder gezählt hat
Das war doch ja das muss preorder sein weil das war in eu noch nicht draußen
Das kam ja irgendwie zuerst asien von der zeitzone her
Und da habe ich es gekauft in der hoffnung das läuft schon
Ok domination spielt keiner
Siehst du das
Spiel keiner
Doch jetzt
Ja ein gestartetes game sind wir reingekommen glaube ich
Wenn wir verlieren dann verlieren wir wenigstens keine punkte
Es gibt tatsächlich eine rangliste
Es gibt ein ranking modus
Eine rangliste
Gab es das nicht bei den letzten kotz rank modus
Ich glaube diesmal kommt es mit dem ziel
Haben wir nicht gekauft
Leute wisst ihr das
Es gab es nicht mit dem rank modus
Wo kommen sie denn jetzt
Checks nicht spawn geflippt
Hat er gerade gesagt Käse ist lost
Ja so ähnlich Käser
Käser
Ich habe Käse ist lost verstanden
Käse
Ich dachte die deutschen sind komisch aber die englischen bringen es ja echt
Gehen wir in eine andere Richtung
Käser
Die sind alle tot
Du musst ja voll suchen nach gegner
Die sind aber guck mal wir dominieren die übelst
Abgeliegt
Beachter
Du weißt wenigstens halbwegs wo was ist
Deswegen spielt wahrscheinlich keiner
Das ist übrigens auch kein dedicated server
Wir sind auf dem p2p
Das stream ruckelt jetzt nicht es sind nur 30 fps weil das game aus irgendwelchen gründen halt nicht funktioniert
Ich habe wieder frame loss ich habe keinen bock mehr
Spiel die runde fertig dann mal schluss nervt mich geht mir echt auf den sack
Ja ja beim angeblich beim capture
Mr frames
Wahrscheinlich am game liegen
Ja aber trotzdem
Also rechner ist da nicht zu schlecht
Läuft das auch
Ausgeben
Granaten random fallen
Käser
Ja ich sehe es das stream ruckelt übelst nervt mich ich mach gleich aus
Das hat noch kein game bisher gepackt dass ich wegen dem spiel den stream ausgemacht habe
Ich wein
Ihr wart jetzt ja schon teilweise offisch mal beim stream jetzt öfters dabei es gab noch nie technische probleme erst seitdem wir
Spielen
Der ansage
Also ich sehe es ja dass ich dass ich frames frames droppe hier übelst viele frames 14%
Das ist so geil ich habe den übelsten input lag wenn ich raus davon wieder reingehe also die pc der pc ist absolute
Krutze
Der modus ist aber gar nicht so übel da weißt du wirklich wo die gegner herkommen
Deswegen spielte keiner
Nein das will ich nicht spielen habe ich keinen Bock drauf
Zum glück gibt es keinen noobtube oder hast du schon einen gesehen
Das ist so nervig die brand munition ist so nervig
Ja extra für leute die daneben schießen aber dann trotzdem kill bekommen ja das ist richtig das ging in der beta schon ein mega auf den sack und jetzt
Ich weiß nicht woran das liegt also heute war Schluss das game hat mir echt die laune da als irgendwie am spielen verdorben gerade macht es gut